[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
pour cette soirée exceptionnelle de
débat sur france 3 des débats consacrés
aux élections municipales dont le
premier tour se déroulera je vous le
rappelle ce dimanche des échanges des
controverses les programmes et les idées
c'est sur france 3 en première partie de
soirée et on en est très fière et après
dijon cap sur sens à l'extrémité nord de
l'yonne
un débat que j'ai le plaisir d'animer
avec renault candelier de france bleu
auxerre bonsoir renault bonsoir lilian
bonsoir à tous sens ville de 25000
habitants à 110 km de paris dans ce
qu'on appelle la quatrième couronne de
la capitale
la preuve environ 5000 personnes par
jour prennent le train pour aller
travailler à paris on est au carrefour
de deux autoroutes sens a donc un atout
sa position géographique les candidats
ici présents proposent tous de renforcer
l'attractivité de cette ville est les
sénonais me demande plus de commerces en
centre-ville plus d'animations plus de
médecins mais aussi plus d'emploi et de
sécurité
deux tiers d'entre eux habitent les
quartiers populaires notamment les
champs plaisants où à chaque élection
les abstentionnistes sont majoritaires
et six têtes de liste sur notre plateau
pour ce débat bonjour à la halle aux
sports
bonjour vous êtes la maire sortante
c'est votre deuxième mandat et vous
mener une liste de droite soutenus par
les républicains élus dei
bonjour laurent monnaie bonjour votre
liste s'appelle le bon sens elle
existait déjà en 2014 et vous êtes
soutenu entre autres par le ps mathieu
bitoun l'histoire et les reliques et les
radicaux de gauche pour ça que j'avais
dit entre autre victoire vous mener la
liste écologiste sous les couleurs
d'europe écologie avec le soutien de la
france a soumises et du pc de génération
écologie m également il fallait de leur
ajouter face avoue claude vivier le gode
bonsoir soins et vous aviez été
candidate en 2014 à la tête d'une liste
divers droite et c'est vous qui avez lu
pour ces élections le label du parti
présidentiel la république en marche et
invite médical et du mouvement radical
merci de la précision investiture michel
crouzet que vous n'avez pas eu bon soir
à vous vous avez été élu député l'yonne
en 2017 sous les couleurs de la
république en marche mais votre parti ne
vous a pas choisi pour ces élections
municipales vous l'avez donc quitter et
vous vous présenter sans étiquette
enfin bon soir julien au 12e
vous êtes le candidat du rassemblement
national dont vous présidez le groupe au
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté et rajoutons que dans cette
élection josé carrasco portera les
couleurs de lutte ouvrière premiers
chapitres de ce débat nous allons parler
de la relation de sens avec paris
notamment des enjeux économiques qui en
découlent
michel crouzet en tant que député vous
faites souvent les allers retours entre
sens et paris comment la ville de sens
peut-elle mieux tirer parti de sa
position stratégique
bien sûr parce que c'est effectivement
quand on prend régulièrement les
transports pour se rendre sur paris on
se rend compte que on est proche et en
même temps on a le sentiment que la
grande couronne parisienne a du mal à
attirer des parisiens sur sur notre sur
notre notre belle ville pourquoi parce
que effectivement on a un manque
d'attractivité cette attractivité vient
du fait notamment que nous avons pas su
tirer par profit de cette attraction
parisienne nous avons pas assez de
commerçants nous n'avons pas assez de
2-2-2 d'entreprise qui puisse recruter
des personnes parce que notre population
à sens et notamment vieillissante notre
jeunesse s'en va et le fait que notre
génie john s en aille en fait fait ceux
de ce fait nous avons du mal à laisser
les sénonais
justement la ville en pâtit complètement
et nous devons absolument garder notre
jeunesse sur sur le sénonais alors
l'idée c'est garder les gens claude
vivier ce que vous partagez ce point de
vue ou qui aussi a vu une partie de
votre vie je ne sais pas si je sais pas
s'il ya eu un point de vue je dirais que
sens à une identité bourguignonne est
une réalité économique d'ile-de-france
donc sans c'est un petit peu comme ces
villes frontalières qui joue entre une
identité régionale
et puis une attractivité économique
national sens doit lutter contre le fait
de venir de devenir une ville dortoir
donc il faut surtout faire très
attention dans cette volonté d'attirer
des franciliens nous devons attirer des
entreprises mais certainement pas des
franciliens je pense que tout le monde
sera d'accord sur ce plateau pour qu'on
ne vienne pas une ville dortoir
l'attractivité de la ville c'est une
attractivité qui passe par son identité
régionale
une culture de la gastronomie et des
beaux bâtiments et nous souhaitons que
la ville de sens puissent obtenir le
label de ville d'art et d'histoire pour
pouvoir lui redonner cette attractivité
sur plan économique nous avons un
territoire assez restreint puisque nous
n'avons que 126 mètres carrés pas pardon
hectares de zones industrielles
par chance la zone c'est autant étendu
d'un tiers simplement j'attire
l'attention sera fait qui peut être un
petit peu dangereux c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il ya 700 m² pour un salarié 700 m² pour
un salarié ce qui veut donc dire que
nous avons une obligation dans cette
augmentation de zones industrielles
d'attirer des entreprises non pas qu'ils
auraient qui serait gourmande de hangar
mais plutôt gourmand de verticalité
je vous coupe pour paris oui bon je
tombe par marie-luce fort sur cette
question d'attirer les entreprises il
faut faire venir à sens des entreprises
de paris c'est ça l'un des objectifs
n'est pas forcément de paris je pense
surtout qu'il faut qu'on cultive ce que
nous sommes ce que nous avons tenté de
faire il ne l'avons rappelée dans le
bilan en vendant un petit peu l'image de
paris ça a été l'objet d'une campagne de
marketing dans les métros ça nous a
amené 8% plus de visiteurs cet été
d'après les chiffres de l'office de
tourisme
il faut qu'on fasse connaître notre
ville et surtout la doter de
d'équipements qui permettent par exemple
la venue de m
on va en parler sans doute la venue de
cadres parce que si on veut des
entreprises faut des cadres et la venue
d'une population diversifiée faut pas
les sonorités assez fait ça on essaie de
le faire mais il faut lui laisser un peu
de temps au temps disait je crois que
c'était mitterrand qui quelle est cette
chose là c'est à dire que ce qu'il faut
c'est réussir à faire en sorte je donne
un exemple il ya fmc par exemple qui a
beaucoup de mal à faire venir des cadres
on a beaucoup de mal à faire venir des
fonctionnaires des enseignants et c'est
donc notre point de vue et puis il faut
pas exagérer on est maire on n'est pas
entrepreneurs ce qui veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on assure l'accueil et qu'on
aménage et la grande la grande ambiguïté
de l'élu à l'heure actuelle c'est de
dire je vais faire venir des commerces
où je vais faire ce qu'il faut c'est
donner les conditions dans vie et les
conditions de vie de ces structures
julien de réagir pendant quand on
interroge un petit peu les l'essai
donnait sur ce qui les a poussés à ce
stade est recensé notamment sur le
principal atout de notre ville c'est la
proximité avec paris
c'est ce qui revient à chaque fois
devant tours devant le cadre de vie
devant l'environnement devant le
patrimoine c'est la proximité avec l'île
de france
mais malheureusement ce que l'on
constate c'est que nous avons les
mauvais côtés des banlieues parisiennes
dire que nous avons une jupe
nous avons des commerces qui ferment en
centre-ville
nous avons également de la violence de
la délinquance
nous avons aujourd'hui de la pauvreté et
nous ne bénéficions pas finalement de
l'attractivité de paris nous ne faisons
pas rayonné notre ville et ça je dirais
il ya un seul responsable
ou plutôt plusieurs responsables seller
des bulles sortant les élus de ce
territoire depuis des années et est vrai
que marie louise fort qui est quand même
élu il faut le rappeler depuis 1977 sur
ce territoire est lui sous giscard
d'estaing à saint clément
elle a été conseillère municipale elle
était adjointe elle a été une fois merle
est débattue elle a été maire depuis six
ans elle était députée pendant dix ans
elle était vice président de la région
qu'ederson fait bien monsieur 12
et madame la sortante pour faire
rayonner notre territoire et pour faire
en sorte qu bénéficient de cette
proximité rien alors rien du alors
madame force et donc c'est vrai s'amuse
en danger pas de publicité dans le métro
parisien
on a fait venir dix ans rien ça c'est la
communication
mais concrètement on va vous répondre et
elle va vous répondre sens 2020 ses sens
2000 rien c'est ce que vous incarnez
vous avez le sens de la formule
on voit la divatte plateau à la lune est
dit et malgré l'entente autan vous
faites du slogan c'est là que vous avez
dû ranger les villes je faisais pas
interrompu je vous devait interroger les
gens de sens pour savoir ce qu'il pense
sur sa vie et on vient chez moi je n'ai
rien caché du tout j'ai dit que j'étais
j'ai parlé d'expérience j'ai parlé de
continuité pourquoi parce que justement
sens a beaucoup souffert d'une faillite
retentissante en l'an 2000 quand je suis
arrivé en 2001 et ensuite de quoi d'une
alternance sans arrêt des équipes qui
fait que les projets et vous le savez
pas encore fini vous parlez délinquance
monsieur odoul résout une famille de
l'intérieur monsieur odoul et vous vous
trompez de casquettes
alors attendez que votre championne
devienne présidente de la république
qu'elle vous nomme comment ministre de
l'intérieur il y en a deux qui attendent
patiemment pouvoir
puisqu il se trouve que j'habite à sens
depuis dix ans monsieur giuly passe
depuis peu de temps
je suis venu de paris pour m'installer
dans cette ville donc elle est
attractive se trouve qu'il ya des gens
qui arrivent je suis cadre supérieur je
travaille sur paris je suis navetteurs
gens le plus urgent de prendre le train
depuis longtemps ça se passait très bien
il se trouve que depuis maintenant
depuis plus de deux ans les conditions
sont beaucoup dégradées donc je pense
que si on veut améliorer la qualité de
vie de
nos concitoyens navetteurs il faudrait
avoir une vraie un vrai échange avec la
région j'ai commencé à prendre contact
avec quelques élus à la région pour
qu'il y ait quelque chose d'eux qu'ils
soient faits aujourd'hui on met
généralement plus d'une heure pour faire
paris sens quand je suis arrivé on était
cinquante cinq minutes c'est parce que
j'appelle le sens du progrès voilà ça
c'est le dernier en même temps qu'elle
veut non le commencer la région elle a
le plus grand mal à obtenir de qualif je
pense qu'il ya un rôle de la ville à
jouer pour aider accompagner les usagers
dans les épreuves qu'ils endurent
parfois ce que des fois c'est très dur
ça marche presque mieux quand il ya des
grèves
donc ensuite second point section veut
rendre notre ville attractive il faut y
créer de l'activité si possible de
l'activité non délocalisables nous on a
des projets dans ce sens là qu'ils
soient en plus écologique parce qu'il
faudrait qu'on parle un petit peu de ça
on va y revenir vers la création
excusez-moi d'une ceinture verte à sens
de maraîchage bio ça c'est des activités
non délocalisables qui servira nos
cantines bio et ensuite c'est aussi
c'est aussi le fait de rendre une ville
avec une meilleure qualité de vie de
retrouver un cinéma de centre-ville
parce que quand on a fait énormément de
projets d'expansion et d'étalement d'une
ville forcément après le centre ville
ils en souffrent elle est en fait
rebondir l'euro monnaie sûre merci
directives et merci de votre patience
on parle on parle effectivement des
choses qui dépendent de l'état on parle
également des choses qui dépendent de la
région j'aimerais bien qu'on parle de
choses qui dépendent de sens et des
municipales avant toute chose
effectivement sens est plutôt bien placé
puisque vous l'avez souligné en
introduction pas très loin de paris
typiquement on est on est à la sortie de
la de la région bourgogne mais aussi on
est à l'entrée d'île de france
donc ça c'est un atout géographique avec
lequel il faut jouer et savoir jouer
alors
par exemple il faut aussi connaître la
typologie des sénonais faut savoir que
tout à l'heure on parlait des quartiers
on parlait un certain nombre de choses
mais qui les connaît véritablement qui
connaît le centre ville qui connaît la
typologie de la population un tiers de
la population par exemple à plus de 60
ans à sens
un tiers de la population 40 % et 40 %
entre deux exactement
voilà pour avoir des chiffres exacts
mais 32 % ce qui veut dire que c'est
énorme
donc ça veut dire que derrière vous avez
des métiers vous avez des professions
qui vont se développer notamment du
service à la personne et le service à la
personne aujourd'hui ça fait cruellement
défaut aux sénonais michel creuser vous
êtes un peu en retard c'est pour ça que
je reviens je reviens sur l'élément
fondamental c'est notre jeunesse et la
cohésion sociale qu'on peut y apporter à
cette ville
c'est pas la peine d'aller chercher des
franciliens donc lui-même différence
parce qu'il y avait l'idée dé metella
personnes pour une population
vieillissante et mettez à personne mais
qui va s'occuper de nos personnes âgées
et c'est bien là forcément les plus de
60 ans qui vont s'occuper formés
localement donc j'y tiens énormément
c'est que notre jeunesse on doit les
jeunes aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe ils passent le bac et ils vont
faire leurs études ailleurs ils ne
reviennent pas il faut absolument qu'on
puisse les conserver sur notre
territoire il faut qu'on offre une offre
de formations adéquates pour que nos
jeunes puissent rester sur le territoire
ya des parents qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'envoyer leurs jeunes faire des études
ailleurs donc offrons des possibilités
pour que les jeunes restent sur le
territoire soient embauchés sur le
territoire et comme les entreprises on
le soulignait tout un leurre
effectivement elle manque d'effectif
mais entreprises ne peuvent pas venir si
effectivement elle n'ont pas le
personnel nécessaire dans notre ville
donc il faut d'abord qu'on forme notre
perdre les jeunes et les moins jeunes un
peu ce qui lui en ont besoin et
qu'ensuite on réponde aux entreprises et
les entreprises viendront parce qu'elles
auront un bassin d'emploi valable c'est
pas possible autrement vous avez dû vous
avez dit quelque chose qu'on entend
beaucoup c'est les jeunes qui partent et
qui reviennent pas dans tous nos débats
sur sur les villes de la région
il ya autre chose qu'on a entendu
énormément dans tous nos débats sur les
villes de la région ces les
centre-villes c'est la dimension des
centre-villes on sait qu'il ya même une
action nationale s'appelle coeur de
ville qui a été lancée là dessus parce
que toutes les villes moyennes de france
à peu prendre des difficultés mais avec
des solutions et des visions différentes
finalement de ce qu'on peut faire qui
vont
de la piétonnisation et du bannissement
des voitures au fait de faire revenir
par exemple les voitures dans les
centres villes laurent monnaie dans
votre campe dans votre programme je
crois il ya un bon paquet de
propositions sur les centres villes
c'est quoi votre vision vous du
centre-ville de sans cesse que ce qui a
été fait vous satisfait est ce que vous
feriez autrement alors autrement oui est
ce que ça peut me satisfaire en partie
j'allais dire il faut savoir déjà que ce
qui est important pour que les
commerçants puissent travailler c'est
créer du flux et du trafic
la mairie n'est pas là pour absolument
une municipalité n'est pas là pour tout
financer une municipalité est là pour
mettre des connexions en place et elle
peut mettre des connexions sur le
commerce à travers des animations à
travers à travers tout ce qu'on peut
mettre en place pour favoriser le
commerce pour créer du flux pour créer
du trafic et à ceux partir de ce moment
là les commerçants s'affairent leur
travail flonflons leur confiance ils
savent faire le travail
claude vivier vous avez une proposition
sur cette problématique spécifique du
centre-ville notamment pour la grande
rue de sens qui l'a l'artère commerciale
oui la problématique du commerce hors en
ville et j'irai plus largement des
entreprises peut-être qu'on laisse un
peu la fiscalité est ce que tout à
l'heure on a oublié de préciser que la
cfe dans le intercommunaux talent est
exactement deux fois le jet exactement
du double de celles du département et du
double de celle du départ de la
contribution foncière des entreprises
voilà l'ancien l'ancien on ne peut pas
on n'attire pas des abeilles avec du
miel avec du vinaigre
excusez moi j'étais un peu sûr parce que
je me suis demandé tout à l'heure si on
était vraiment dans la même ville j'irai
on parle de développement économique
mais finalement on oublie quand même que
les entreprises pour les attirer pour
peut-être baisser un petit peu les taxes
et le fond et le prix du foncier pour le
centre-ville de la même façon on ne peut
pas jeter l'opprobre sur la mairie
sortante du fait qu'ils aient pas de
commerce qui fonctionne puisque hincapie
personne qui vient centre ville nous
sommes à 17% de moins de revenus moyens
aux chiens énorme aux portes de bien aux
champs certes mais quand on est étonné
que nous avons
mais quand nous avons comme nous avons
un jeu c'est surtout que madame -
habitent deux sens depuis un petit peu
de temps vous vois déjà débat
démocratique
on l'a terminé parce que vous avez un
peu de retard mais je viens d'où les
invaincus moman termine et cody hay mais
vos contradictions sont vos conditions
soient là le revenu moyen des sénonais
et 17 % plus faible que le revenu
national d'eau rue à partir du moment où
l'on dit je suis d'accord qui est un
taux de pauvreté que c'est augmenter la
ville s'est paupérisée donc les
commerces à sens ce qui existe
fonctionne à peu près bien mais il n'y a
pas de place pour tout le monde est
aujourd'hui la grande rue devient un
désert parce qu'il n'y a plus personne
qui vient qu'il y à fond c'est des fous
de samedi de plomb
alors mes ennuis on en venait à long
terme en matière
vous avez des vous allez je suis donc je
suis vous ils voient pas de moi je vais
vous dire annonce était désert il vous
plaît on laisse dans l'ordre et pons
m'était vraiment un jeu de rugby dont
vous avez la parole à l'exit ninon
besson c'est une ville où le samedi il y
a beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se passaient une ville qui bouge il
faudrait libérer beaucoup de beaucoup
d'activités remonte de l'animation
remettre de la vie culturelle ça c'est
sûr c'est sans doute pas votre programme
météo doute faire tondre par des chèvres
bordeaux par des moutons faudrait
peut-être réviser un peu avant de
composer n'importe quoi non je pense que
c'est une ville qui en centre ville
pourrait bouger beaucoup plus moi je
pense que je crois beaucoup notamment à
la réimplantation d'un cinéma de
centre-ville communales ou associatives
qui permettra notamment aux
restaurateurs de retrouver une activité
plus plus importantes notamment en
soirée les week-ends et vous le financer
comment ce cinéma centre ville
c'est un cinéma associatif communal vous
croyez moi c'est des coûts beaucoup
moins élevé que des dépenses
pharaoniques qu'on a fait récemment tout
est une question de priorité en dépenses
à madame et redoutent que vous passiez
le financer ce que vous voulez faire une
université ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
que je viens redouble sur cette question
de la problématique du centre-ville
comment refaire revenir des commerces
vous vous promettez qu'il n'y aura plus
aucune boutique vide si vous êtes élu
maire oui je le sentais mieux jeu
finalement je me avancent un bilan qui
est ce l'avis des maires des mairies
rassemblement national gérons nous
faisons revenir les commères donc ça
marche ya pas de fatalité en vous faites
comment il n'y a pas de fatalité
je vais vous le dire j'ai il faut partir
d'un constat pourquoi ça marche pas à
source
tout simplement parce qu'on a fait
d'autres choix et madame fort a fait
d'autres choix
en 2014 il faut se rappeler que dans son
bilan elle voulait pérenniser le
commerce en centre ville et le disait la
main sur le coeur vous le disiez à
bicyclette
le problème c'est que quand il ya le
coeur et est devenu un bloc de granit et
la visite est les parties zone sud
vous ne pouvez pas pérenniser le
commerce en centre ville si vous
implanter une immense dans le commercial
qui va faire vous faites quoi vous la
fermez vous l'avons commercial je verrai
ce faire mais évidemment évidemment mais
du coup on a dit stack est en effet
quand on dit que la zone commerciale
c'est pas bien justement je vous le dis
il faut faire revenir les consommateurs
et les touristes en centre ville c'est à
dire qu'avec des places de parking et
des parkings intelligent qui sait un peu
plus moderne que ce qu'on a actuellement
des parcs il faut que les parkings qui
sont jaunes sud mais qui en house qui en
est aussi au centre ville pour faire
venir donc des touristes et des
consommateurs et puis faut qu'il y ait
aussi des raisons de venir à 130%
désarmement de parler de compte par les
pilotes par les deux éléments étaient
aussi dans mon programme remettre un
cinéma en centre ville je souhaite
également apporter un cabaret pour qui
véritable une vie culturelle une vie
culturelle qui a été démantelée aussi
par marie louise fort puisqu'elle a elle
s'est acharnée contre la mjc dont qui
faisait un très très gros travail un
travail très intéressant pour la culture
pour tous
donc tout ça permet aussi de faire venir
des gens qui consomment qui vivent à
sens et qu'ils aient tout simplement
envie de vivre en ville aujourd'hui
c'est plus le cas malheureusement marc
antoine hey hey baby sport répond qu'on
vous laissera répond très bien
bon moi je pense qu on pose les
mauvaises questions où on se pose les
vraies questions faut partir tout
simplement du constat effectivement on
parlait stationnement ses 2900 places de
parking sur sens
alors c'est presque un faux problème
j'allais dire le parking créer du flux
créer du trafic alors je le répète vous
allez dire mais pourquoi ne pas imaginer
une navette entre le nord et le sud une
navette gratuite à des fréquences
régulières qui permettrait effectivement
aux personnes qui ne souhaitent pas
utiliser leur véhicule en centre-ville
de pouvoir s'y rendre ce qui existe dans
certaines ce qui existe dans certaines
iniquités sociales et fonctionne et qui
fonctionne à l'électrique et pourquoi
pas pour faire saisir monsieur bitoun
parce que derrière ma plaisanterie il ya
que faire venir les voitures dans les
centre-villes c'est pas franchement dans
l'air du temps mais non et puis les
jeunes engagés les espaces partagés les
espions qui vont oublier qu'il y avait
une urgence écologique aussi partager
les espaces parce que images il ya des
personnes âgées
la population est vieillissante et si on
peut pas venir chercher si on peut pas
venir se rapprocher du centre-ville pour
venir consommer ces personnes là n'ont
pas non plus venir pour ça il faut
paralyser le fait de rester et puis
surtout rester en centre ville centre
ville il faut pas rester trente minutes
qu'il faut rester pour un achat
raisonner il faut rester au moins deux
heures
il a positionné des passionnés de la
place de la voiture alors marie louise
marleau qui serait d'accord pour mais
c'est terminé c'est quoi votre
stationnement et augmenter la période
effectivement c'est important un achat
raisonnée c'est au-delà d'une demi heure
aujourd'hui donc il faut pousser à 2
heures prestées a demandé des précisions
sur la question il ya 10 900 places
effectivement avec du parking payant
mais aussi du parc 2028 même un peu plus
mai 2009 bon merci à vous heureusement
que vous êtes là non je voudrais dire
tout à l'heure je j'écoute mais je ne
partage pas les histoires de grandes
surfaces ça vous a pas échappé que les
grandes surfaces en ce moment ferme on
en a une qui a fermé et ça
malheureusement il ya des surfaces de
moins de 1000 mètres carrés qui peuvent
s'installer sans vous en soyez au
courant et vous découvrir
et donc mais peu importe de toute façon
tous ces gens là ça fait tomber ou telle
forme et on le sait bien
laissez-moi terminée moi je pense que
pour récupérer le centre ville c'est pas
d'aller distribuer des sacs med in india
india en centre ville pour faire la pub
de votre mouvement
mais c'est effectivement de se donner la
capacité d'attirer les gens on a rénové
le marché couvert
on a aménagé les places on a fait en
sorte de donner envie d'aller se
promener
on a on a fait d aménagement de
terrasses on subventionne pour toutes
les terrasses soit de la même couleur
les et les animations je vais vous en
dire quelques unes ya une patinoire à
noël il ya de la retransmission des
matchs 12 me soit un bon point mais ça
va venir
attendez je suis en train de vous dire
ce qu'on fait on maintient attaqué sur
les animations
je suis désolé il ya beaucoup
d'animations centre-ville d'autre part
pour notre part nous reçoive un gros
mensonge est membre non désolé pour cent
de vacances commercial et et je pense
que je vais rentrer je pense maintenant
non mais attendez il faut quand même pas
exagérer moi je vais vous dire ce que je
voudrais pas vous montrer quelque chose
c'est la carte de l'insee bon tout ce
qui est en gris il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de population il n'y a
pas de ya pas de dynamisme tellement le
corps n'avions que je voudrais quand
même pas voir la rondelle un petit peu
au ballon mais vous remarquerez tout
seul
celle de charlie sheen républicaines
sont meilleurs que les chiffres de
l'insee
l'élysée de prend à rêver de madame
pauline finale qu'on est en train de
mourir celui-ci n'est pas bonne non
millimes sait de quelle année est
maintenant en ligne cnet incapable de
donner des chiffres dans les basses
toujours ces chiffres seront moins trois
ans d'ancienneté des jeunes en délire
dans l'ordre on les stars neymar et du
sport c'est en ces termes je
n'interviendrai personnes oui mais je
voudrais terminer ça parce que ça veut
dire quoi il faut quand même quelques
outils à assen à un pourcentage près
quelques outils pour fixer le cap alors
le cap c'est de dire qu'il faut
diversifier la population on est bien
d'accord
il ya actuellement entre 30 et 35 % de
population très social et on est en
train de vouloir faire revenir je
pourrai alors on met on oppose les
cheese à winnezeele désolé de 12 4% de
de vacances qui sont en osmose avec s'il
voulait plus répondre aux deux pistolets
je suis désolé la plupart des gens
peuvent se les gèle vous plaît ils l'ont
mais voudrait terminer fort une chose à
leur faire de l'attractivité qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a essayé de garder notre
chef étoilé ou patrick gauthier c'est à
la madeleine est pas là on a essayé de
garder et de faire en sorte que perdure
un bon poissonnier des bons marchands de
vêtements autour du clocher couleurs
rennaises
mais la journée non non non a fini
terminé très rapidement je suis sur le
commerce oui mais vous avez beaucoup
parlé beaucoup plus que tout il ya des
banques je voudrais dire également qu'on
a eu un pâtissier meilleur ouvrier de
france qui est un ami qui sépare les
onze on est en train les on est en train
de regagner de l'attractivité c'est
votre ville très bien voilà je la veux
tu vraiment je suis vraiment d'accord il
ya une vacance commercial kit énorme en
centre ville
et puis si on veut que les gens
reviennent il faut des enseignes qui
attire pour cela moi ce que je propose
c'est que effectivement on a condédé
commerce de bourges tout va très bien et
qu'ils sont meilleurs de france tout va
très bien mais on a on a des grandes
enseignes à l'extérieur commercial eh
bien il faut leur demander de pouvoir
déplacer une partie de leurs activités
dans le centre ville je prends des ex en
bien des villes dans lequel de décathlon
à décathlon leur demander d'apporter une
activité en centre-ville en disant
peut-être de les réparer des vélos vente
cocktail vélo et ça pourrait très bien
donc il faut attirer des ombres dans des
temps des grandes enseignes
il faut qu elle délocalise une partie de
leur activité en centre-ville ça se fait
dans certaines maisons
le jour où les fnac sont venus en dans
les centres-villes et bien ça a fait
venir du monde
on a pu heureusement il faut sauvegarder
d'ailleurs lié aux panneaux libre aider
le commerce il faut concentrer vos
propositions il nous reste un gros quart
d'heure et on n'aura pas un quart
d'heure suivant parce qu'il faudra vos
conclusions
donc donc maintenant voilà on va passer
à la suite savez très bien troisième et
dernier chapitre de ce débat sens
évidemment à des quartiers comme comme
toutes les villes va commencer par le
plus grand d'entre eux le quartier des
champs plaisants souvent appelé zune par
les sénonais et aussi de quartier de la
guerre quartiers résidentiels comme
saint béat tout le quartier saint paul
par exemple un vibrant dans son quartier
fait notamment se sentir en sécurité
mathieu bitoun est ce que c'est un axe
sur lequel vous travaillez rien tant que
maire déjà sur les quartiers
effectivement il ya un vrai travail à
faire ce qu'on est dans une ville qui
est très fracture est très morcelé
très peu de communication d'un quartier
à l'autre c'est vraiment quelque chose
sur lequel il faut travailler il faut
aussi travailler sur beaucoup plus de
vie et d'animation dans les différents
quartiers nous on a un projet de mettre
en place cinq maisons de quartier de la
citoyenneté
parce que la démocratie participative
c'est aussi un axe qu'on trouve très
important dont une citoyenne à la base
même si on a des soutiens et après sur
la sécurité
si vous parlez de sécurité j'imagine que
vous voulez parler de sûreté sur ce
sujet là on a une surenchère entre les
listes de droite qui ils veulent
absolument en faire le sujet principal
on parle beaucoup de vidéo protection
vont toutes les études semblent
démontrer que la vidéoprotection n'a
aucune utilité sauf dans mon milieu
fermé
donc nous on fera un moratoire on
essaiera d'avoir des chiffres parce
qu'on a actuellement aucun disponibles
malheureusement pour pouvoir se faire
une idée précise et après on a ça nous a
coûté ça nous coûte beaucoup d'argent
puisque ont des frais de maintenance
sont à notre charge c'est plus de 500000
euros par an quand même de frais avec
les centaines de caméras fait de calculs
rapidement et après on a perdu aussi des
des fonctionnaires de police nationale
est en fait bien sûr lutter contre pour
lutter contre la criminalité les trafics
bas il faut des fonctionnaires de police
nationale puisque des caméras weavil
fracture est effectivement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui vous l'avez souligné il
ya un quartier quartier des champs
plaisants qui est un petit peu délaissé
un petit peu délaissé et pour le coup on
n'a pas fait grand chose quand je dis on
c'est la municipalité en place puisque
et sainte béate et les arènes et l'école
paul-bert par exemple parlons-en puisque
c'est un collègue albert j'ai été
remboursés de leur fille depuis 2016 sur
la base de quatre cent mille euros
on rappelle l'école l'école maternelle
qui a brûlé il est installé dans les
locaux de chandelles ou avec une salle
d'évolution la plus moderne de la ville
et avec tous les équipements
attention
150 s'il vous plaît 150 euros par élève
on est loin du compte on laisse parler
de façon je ne dis pas n'importe quoi
effectivement et en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement je connais un certain
nombre de choses et notamment les
chiffres et les implantations sur le
secteur de la ville
ça ça a été un élément ça a été un
élément paul béret et bien sûr par
exemple les l'opposition s'est battu
pour une navette puisque vous savez que
des familles étaient complètement éclaté
entre deux établissements
il n'avait à 20000 euros et ça pour le
coup par an alors que la municipalité
n'a pas souhaité le mettre en place et
c'est simplement du service à la
population
claude vivier quel est le quartier
prioritaire s'il y en a un à sens la
ville dont on doit s'occuper la ville
moi je suis choquée qu'on parle de
quartier j'estime qu'il ya une ville
unique une entité qui a des problèmes
écologiques hippologie particulière ce
sont les équipes précédentes qui ont
voulu c'est typologie aujourd'hui je
suis désolé madame fin vous n'êtes pas
la maire de la ville de sange est la
mère du centre ville de sens donc c'est
regrettable
nous nous souhaitons la preuve c'est que
les comités de quartier ont été
supprimés nous souhaitons impérativement
remettre les comités de quartier et
travaille en priorité sur les trois
quartiers qui ont été totalement
abandonnée avec un taux de pauvreté là
pour le coup les chiffres de l'insee
je les connais par coeur j'ai pas besoin
de carte et 52% taux de pauvreté entre
arènes chaillot et ce en plein champs
plaisants avec la remise en place des
écoles de proximité et surtout pas à
cette tendance à la ghettoïsation avec
un complexe scolaire que vous voulez
créer une cité éducative où on va
plonger les petits c'est une super
marché de l'enfance comme je l'appelle
donc je suis foncièrement contre et
c'est au sein de l'arène du programme de
rénovation des champs-plaisants que je
souhaite réhabiliter la mjc non pas la
refaire la faire revenir la réhabiliter
parce qu'elle a montré sa capacité à
être un acteur de l'agglomération ont
défait d'avant-soirée parler de la santé
j'aimerais parler de la santé cette
revitalisation des quartiers aujourd'hui
la santé dans moins de 3 ans et 15 mille
sénonais qui n'auront plus de médecins
traitants nous avons placé la santé au
coeur de notre programme et nous
souhaitons relocaliser des médecins
n'ont pas faire des centres de santé il
y en a déjà deux seins qui est
d'ailleurs la santé doit être une
préoccupation de l'agglo
ration 1 sur saint clément et un en
centre-ville privé nous souhaitons real
rilke est-ce que c'était pour localiser
relocaliser ces remettre un médecin à
proximité
pourquoi parce que les muppets comment
vous la première des choses c'est que la
municipalité doit en effet mettre en
place des moyens et trouver des
bâtiments adaptés avec les normes
handicapés pour éviter aux médecins de
fermer un peu plus vite actuellement
avec la tasse de 40000 euros qui leur
semble un détail en deux ans on donne la
parole à julien odoul furent ceux sur le
sujet le quartier oui la sécurité c'est
la priorité de nos concitoyens et ils
l'expriment chaque jour j'étais encore
hier dans le quartier des arènes où je
discutais avec une mère de famille qui
me disait je ne sors plus avec mes trois
petites filles parce qu'on se fait
caillasser
on se fait cracher dessus on se fait
insulter il n'y a pas de caméra dans le
quartier on se sent totalement abandonné
et c'est vrai que en l'espèce le sur le
front de la sécurité
marie louise fort c'est vraiment marrer
luis faible parce qu'elle a échoué sur
tout et se les îles encore mieux mais il
en fiction jeudi lancer véritablement
goulet s'est marré malo et
malheureusement dans l'est
malheureusement ce boulet les sénonais
qui le subissent et qu'il traîne au
quotidien vous le boulot les effectifs
de police municipale contrairement à ce
qui était dit n'ont jamais été
renforcées jamais été renforcée
aujourd'hui la volonté municipale et les
projets terminés mais qu'il serait bon
jour peut maintenant aujourd'hui je peux
terminer il ya neuf policiers municipaux
opérationnelle non poèmes cité lorient
et nantes a annoncé qu'un avis pour 3,8
et donner les prénoms des
[Musique]
before ne connaît pas vraiment du
dossier d'aujourd'hui ya neuf policiers
il y avait un policier
il nous reste qu il nous reste deux
minutes avant de venir et michel vous
êtes devra par l'insécurité c'est une
problématique concerne le quotidien des
aides de 15 pieds de la sexualisation
d'attendre le jour en même temps il a il
a son temps par le sens aujourd'hui est
en proie à une insécurité massive est
devenue une plaque tournante de la
drogue n'implique chaillot deschaillons
main et vous voulez qu'un mouvoir j'ai
dit oui je vois la vie et vous savez
bien johnny double sinon on va pas s'en
sortir michel crouzet juste un mot alors
des fossés en permanence le code général
des collectivités territoriales dit que
c'est bien le maire qui doit le premier
donc veiller à la sécurité de ses
concitoyens
arrêtez de vous défausser le maire doit
effectivement assurer la sécurité de ses
citoyens
effectivement alors madame la maire
sortante et monsieur odoul vous voulez
des caméras souvent dans tous les coins
de rue les caméras se sont se sont je
vous en prie les caméras ce sont des
outils ce sont des outils qui peuvent
aider la police municipale et police
nationale et procureur a travaillé ce
sont des outils mais la police
municipale doit être dans la rue la
police municipale vous êtes à proximité
des citoyens
on parle de cohésion sociale il faut que
les agents puissent discuter avec les
citoyens sont de plus en plus en contact
avec les citoyens
comment voulez vous remettre de la
situation pour le faire donc à partir de
là bien évidemment et c'est comme ça
qu'il faut agir parce que c'est pas se
dire les caméras ça va résoudre tous les
problèmes
on n'est pas là du tout ce n'est
absolument pas vrai et en plus on doit
aussi aménager le territoire pour qu' il
ya de l'éclairage public pour qu'il y
ait des encours et allez ça qu'ils se
fassent tout petit peu de monnaie
laurent - m haies
pour 30 secondes parce qu'après ce jour
s'il vous plaît elle aura moins de films
avant les conclusions moi je voudrais
terminer effectivement pour clore ce
chapitre de la sécurité
alors qui est un vaste sujet
effectivement mais il faut absolument
renforcer une convention police
municipale saul eu marre en france pays
et définir des missions qui sont tout
autre aujourd'hui voilà il faut changer
c'est que des 100 kg avec les messieurs
castaner madame cruise et ne m'a même
pas soutenue elle a soutenu le préfet
qui avait envie de changer d'endroit une
image n'est pas du tout n'est jamais des
siècles le peuple les policiers
municipaux du commissariat ont une
baisse de d'effectifs d'environ un tiers
depuis dix ans la police nationale et
donc elles sont en nombre insuffisant
pour répondre mon atout c'est ce que
veut dire le nom combien il y a deux
policiers commencent à bouger mais il
faut constater je voudrais quand même
ces moments conclure parce que j'ai
demandé une barre à canon et ce que je
voudrais dire aux sénonais maintenant
tout ce qu'il y à une pétition en
direction du ministre de l'intérieur
avoue que si lyon consignations par
l'ensemble riemer dur mais l'effectif
est un lieu de recrutement alors il faut
le bouclier fiscal ça vous plairait
c'est bien monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur l'histoire c'est le moment
de conclure
on avait prévu une conclusion d'une ça
va être possible mais allez on commence
cette conclusion s'il vous plaît on se
tait par julien ou 12 cents c'est une
ville magnifique est une ville riche de
son patrimoine riche de sa jeunesse
riche de ses talents malheureusement
c'est une ville aujourd'hui qui est
gâchée puisqu'une classe politique donc
la gâcher et c'est notre ville a juste
besoin de volonté de dynamisme
d'ambition ça fait 25 ans que finalement
nous sommes sur la même route à sens
avec des alternances qui n'ont mené à
rien et qui ont gâché le potentiel de
cette ville moi je propose de changer de
sens j'incarne le renouveau incarne
l'espérance et je propose donc
de prendre une autre voie celle du
développement celle du bonheur partagé
celle aujourd'hui de la sécurité pour
tous et du dynamisme
donc n'ayez pas peur de changer de sens
il n'y a aucune crainte à avoir
il faut se rassembler sur un beau projet
un projet de sécurité un projet de
prospérité donc dimanche changé de sens
juste un mot
s'il vous plaît on respecte les
conclusions de tout le monde claude
vivier le gotha votre conclure je vis en
ce sens depuis 35 ans je suis une
cenonnaise de coeur et c'est aujourd'hui
je suis libre de tout engagement
professionnel c'est mon expérience de
chef d'entreprise internationale une
expérience reconnue et de bénévoles
engagés auprès des ong également
d'experts au conseil de l'europe sur des
questions d'éducation et de culture que
je souhaite mettre au service des
sénonais les sénonais me connaissent et
connaissent ma ténacité
je suis une femme d'engagement une
sportive une militante associative qui
aiment convaincre partager et
transmettre
oui aujourd'hui je me présente à vous je
suis entouré d'une équipe de 35
personnes
trente-cinq personnes qui ne se sont pas
usés dans les précédentes équipes
municipales une équipe solidaire une
équipe compétente qui souhaitent placer
la bienveillance et le renouer le
dialogue avec tous les sénonais et tous
les habitants une équipe qui a pris à
bras le corps
le gros problème de la ville de sens qui
est la santé qui l'a lié avec la
sécurité et le développement économique
pour en faire un projet cohérent et
global
je vous remercie michel crouzet pierre
denéchère cenonnaise et cher s'est
donnée le 15 et le 22 mars vous avez la
peau cité de redonner un souffle un élan
à notre ville de réveiller sens vous
pouvez le faire vous pouvez faire de
sens une ville où règne le vivre
ensemble tous les habitants seront
considérés écouter et associés à notre
action municipale
le brassage interquartiers
intergénérationnelle et interculturelle
doit traître une exigence notre projet
est ambitieux et réaliste nos propres
hinault priorités sont claires la
jeunesse et la cohésion sociale fait le
choix de l'expérience et de l'humanisme
fait le choix d'une femme sincère et
proche de vous et de jeu serait pour
vous toutes et tous sans distinction
votre mère
ce dimanche votez et faites voter pour
la liste réveiller sens laurent moinet
vous avez deux minutes pour conclure
alors votez le bon sens et rétablir le
dialogue avec les sénonais sait faire de
sens une ville apaisée une ville modèle
pour tous c'est s'assurer des
opportunités de développement économique
raisonné et durable mais également des
services adaptés à la population avec
une promesse forte c'est qu'à la fin de
notre mandat
chaque sénonais est un médecin traitant
voter le bon sens c'est n'oublier
personne quel que soit son quartier ses
convictions sa condition votez le bon
sens et profiter d'un centre ville et
d'un commerce dynamique avec des
animations régulières et attractive
enfin voter le bon sens c'est faire le
choix d'une ville qui rayonne univers
minh ville vers pardon solidaire
éco-responsable où il fait bon vivre en
toute sécurité et sérénité
merci leur monnaie maccabi tôt oui mais
nous nous sommes une liste citoyenne ça
fait plusieurs mois maintenant que nous
avons travaillé que nous avons essayé
d'établir un diagnostic de la ville en
allant à la rencontre des habitants des
différents acteurs du territoire
ce que nous avons constaté que c'est
qu'on a une ville qui a un énorme
potentiel je pense que beaucoup de gens
m'ont dit mais qui a surtout accumulé
beaucoup de retard et on a identifié en
fait trois besoins qui nous semblent
être des urgences des choses qu'il faut
vraiment maintenant réaliser en priorité
il faut réaliser une révolution
écologique pour aller répondre aux
urgences écologiques et ça il faut le
faire tout de suite il faut réaliser
maintenant répondre aux besoins de
solidarité au besoin de justice sociale
parce qu'on a pris énormément de retard
dans ce dans ce domaine là et enfin il
ya une vraie aspiration en ce moment il
consent partout pour la démocratie
participative
c'est pourquoi nous nous avons ensemble
travailler pendant des mois en atelier
pour faire émerger 120 propositions dans
ces trois domaines la qui en plus vont
aller dans le même sens
ensemble pour que nous puissions
effectivement donner à notre ville de la
chance de devenir un territoire modèle
dans tous ces domaines
merci match habito de marie louise fort
c'est à vous a le dernier mot à l'aube
de ce nouveau mandat et dans le contexte
d'inquiétude qui agitent nos concitoyens
avec l'épidémie qui était en train de se
mettre en place
je tiens je retiens que de ce mandat que
les cenonnaise
et les ces données ont besoin de
proximité avec leur mère et avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe municipale
alors l'équipe de deux sens 2001 est
composée de personnes comme moi
impliqués dans leur ville et surtout
disponible et c'est une équipe qui connu
et reconnu reconnu parce que les
sénonais savent de quoi nous sommes
capables aujourd'hui sens a besoin de
continuité pour faire avancer les grands
projets la rénovation urbaine dans les
quartiers le projet de la gare puisque
nous sommes une des 22 villes et l'ubs
dans le car dans le cadre de coeur de
ville la reconquête de l'île d'yonne
avec le pôle touristique sens a besoin
de continuité pour consolider notre
cadre de vie les écoles les crèches la
propreté la sécurité des commerces avec
mon équipe expérimentée et renouveler
nous sommes prêts à continuer le travail
entrepris
et ce dès le lendemain de l'élection
alors je le répète notre merci marie
louise fort merci j'ai dit merci à tous
les six d'avoir d'être venu jouer le jeu
parfois difficile du débat et de les
changes
merci en australie n'oubliez pas
dimanche le premier tour et son
électorat ce sera sur france bleu et ce
sera chez nous sur france 3 vous saurez
tout de 20h à 23h resté en place le
temps de la fin d'émission
bonne soirée au revoir et bonne soirée à
tous
vous
[Musique]